[Música]
es una parte fundamental de la segunda
vuelta de las elecciones presidenciales
francesas desde 1974 los debates cara a
cara han visto a giscard sarkozy y
holanda enfrentando a sus oponentes y
hay cosas que no se deben repetir
algunos gestos pueden conducir a una
forma de desvelo hacia el oponente una
mirada puede poner al oponente en una
posición inferior
y luego están las frases célebres es
no tienes el monopolio del corazón
electo presidente de la república no
será el líder de la mayoría incluso
cuando los candidatos tienen mucho apoyo
necesitan prepararse para el debate como
demostró marx indepen con su pobre
actuación en 2017
similar
para sumar puntos en un debate como éste
tienes que ser estoico cuando hace el
remate tienen que mirarse a los ojos el
debate de este 20 de abril será el
segundo entre macrón y la penn después
del enfrentamiento lleno de insultos del
2017 es un combate que ningún candidato
puede darse el lujo de perder